خط المواجهة في مكافحة
الفيروس التاجي ، كانت غرفة الطوارئ في بروكلين
لمريض في جامعة ولاية نيويورك داونستيت للعلوم الصحية ، بعد أن كان المريض
يكافح من أجل التنفس هذا الصباح ،
قاسية جدًا اليوم ، حيث
توفي مجموعة من الأشخاص في
فترة زمنية قصيرة جدًا مما أدى إلى  نحن
نعلم أنك مستعدون لذلك ، ولكن عندما
يحدث ذلك مرات عديدة في وردية واحدة ، من
الصعب جدًا تحمله عندما وصلنا إلى
غرفة الطوارئ ، يتم اختتام أحدث ضحية لفيروس كورونا
في SUNY Downstate في
غرفة الطوارئ في Bay حيث
حاول الأطباء إنقاذهم  قمنا بزيارة SUNY
Downstate لمدة ثلاث ساعات تقريبًا في منتصف نهار
الجمعة في الوقت القصير الذي كنا فيه
في غرفة الطوارئ بمفردنا ، ستة مرضى تم
ترميزهم بعبارة أخرى أنهم عانوا من قصور في القلب
أو في الجهاز التنفسي لأنهم ماتوا
جزءًا مدمرًا من يوم واحد فقط وهذا
ما تدربنا عليه  افعل هذا هو ما
سجلناه فقط ليس في هذا المجلد ،
فأنت تعلم أنه قد يكون لديك رمز ربما في
نوبة سيئة ، قد يكون لديك رمزان حيث
تحمل هذا الإيمو  وأنت تتساءل عما إذا
كنت قد فعلت كل ما في وسعك
أعتقد أنه من الصعب عاطفياً الاستعداد
لهذا المستوى من المرض
والمعاناة والمراضة والوفيات في مثل هذه
الفترة القصيرة من الوقت ، ولا أعتقد أن
أيًا منا مستعد جيدًا لذلك.
سبق لك أن رأيت هذا er Jam مثل هذا ليس
تمامًا مثل هذه الأيام ، فأنت لست في
أقصى حد بعد ولكنك تدفعه ، نعم
نحن ندفعه ، لذا في بعض الأحيان
لا يوجد مكان للتحرك في غرفة الطوارئ هنا
لدينا نظام حيث نقوم
بفك ضغطهم بالخلف هنا في
الممرات ، غرفنا الأخرى هي المسار السريع الذي
لم يحضره الكثير من الناس
لأطفالهم ، لذا فقد تولينا
جزءًا من طب الأطفال ،
وهناك أيضًا عيادات هنا
يمكننا التحول إليها  أسرة وينتظرون هناك
بمجرد استقرارها من هنا
ثم يصعدون إلى الطابق العلوي في الممرات الموجودة في غرفة الطوارئ
هنا والتي تصطف مع أولئك الذين يعانون من
مرضى فيروس كورونا الذين لا يستجيبون والذين
يعانون
من الحقيقة الصعبة لهذا الفيروس بالنسبة
لبعض المرضى الذين يهاجمون الرئتين
حرمانهم من الأكسجين
يخنقهم ببطء بسبب
الالتهاب الرئوي ليس فقط في رئة واحدة
بل في كلتا الرئتين مما يترك
المريض بلا رئة جيدة كما أنه
منتشر في جميع أنحاء الرئتين مع
تفاعل التهابي شديد
يضر بالرئة مما يؤدي إلى إصابة أكثر الحالات
الحرجة.  المرضى الذين يعانون من
فيروس كورونا يتنفسون الأمر بسيطًا كما
هو الحال في الطب ولكنه لا يزال لغزًا
لأن الفيروس التاجي يقاوم العلاجات
يربك الأطباء ويقتل المرضى
هنا فيما يتعلق بالمجرى الهوائي ، وعلينا
إدارة مجرى الهواء بمجرد أن
يتغيروا من نقص الأكسجين
إنهم غير قادرين على إبقاء الأمر مفتوحًا
لأنفسهم وما هو معدل الوفيات
بمجرد أن يذهبوا في تنفيس ما
يحدث للوفيات ، فهو يزيد أضعافًا مضاعفة
المزيد من المرضى يموتون بمعنى آخر يفعلون
ذلك ، فالأرقام ليست هي نفسها تمامًا
من بلد إلى آخر وهناك
عوامل مختلفة لذلك ، لكننا نتفق جميعًا
على أنه قفز بسرعة ، فالطبيب لورنزو
بالادينو طبيب الطوارئ الذي قام بذلك
العمل الرائد في وضع أكثر من
شخص على جهاز التنفس الصناعي
هو بحث يأمل
ألا نضطر لاستخدامه هنا أبدًا ما يبقينا مستيقظين في
الليل هو بالضبط ما يحفزنا
للقيام بهذا النوع من البحث هنا في جامعة ولاية نيويورك
داونستيت هو أننا  نريد بديلاً
لمنحه لهؤلاء المرضى ليس فقط
أجهزة التنفس الصناعي ولكن أيضًا لـ CPAP في
تدفق عالي للأكسجين المعزول ، نحاول
جميع أنواع المناورات من أجل
الحفاظ على تنفسهم ومنعهم من
الاختناق أو الإصابة بالسكتة
القلبية وليس فقط في غرفة الطوارئ
حيث يكافح المرضى من أجل التنفس
والكود أثناء إجراء مقابلات مع الأطباء في
أجزاء أخرى من المستشفى ، والإعلانات العامة المستمرة تقريبًا
بأن مريضًا آخر قد قام بترميز
تلك الإعلانات للمرضى الذين تم
قبولهم بالفعل وليس أولئك الموجودين في غرفة الطوارئ ، هل يمكنني
إيقافك لثانية واحدة ، هذا
هو الخامس  أو الكود السادس 99 كود 99 هو
عادة حدث نادر نواجهه ، أود
أن أقول 10 كود 99 كل 12
ساعة.  ar هنا
لمدة 30-40 دقيقة وهذا هو الخامس
أو السادس وما
يمثله الكثير هو دعوة فريق
لوضع مريض على جهاز التنفس
وهو الأمر الأكثر إثارة للجدل حول
رؤية ما بداخل غرفة الطوارئ و
مستشفى ينتقل إلى كونه واحدًا من
ثلاثة في ولاية نيويورك والتي ستعالج فقط
المرضى الذين يعانون من
فيروس كورونا خارجها ، وهي هادئة
وتشعر وكأنها في أوائل أيام الربيع ، فهي
تتحرك ببطء وهي مملّة للكثير من
الناس ولكن هذه كارثة.  هي
بالتأكيد كارثة من الصعب نوعًا
ما على الأشخاص من
عامة الناس الذين لا يعملون في المستشفيات
لأنه عندما تدخل عندما
تقود سيارتك في شارع كلاركسون ، فإنك تقود سيارتك
في جادة نيويورك في أوشن
أفينيو وهي طرق مزدحمة للغاية
يكاد يكون صراصير الليل ولكن هنا في
قسم الطوارئ هو حب
الشدة الذي لا تراه إلا في
مناطق الكوارث التي تم بثها عبر التلفزيون في جميع
أنحاء العالم